footballer he's worth 70 million dollars
he married the actress in 2020 uh her
net worth three million dollars not bad
but footballer akraf akimi's wife has
filed for divorce and demanded half his
property but
there's a catch my friend she was
allegedly allegedly allegedly informed
by the court that her multi-millionaire
husband owns nothing and that all his
properties were registered in his
mother's name I think there's a lesson
here for the men out there especially
for the successful men out there you
might be in love you get married you
think life's Blissful next thing you
know three years later you're 70 million
dollars might be worth 35 million
dollars possibly even less if she gets a
hold of all your assets but he made some
adjustments to his estate planning his
financial planning his asset allocation
and put it all apparently in his mama's
name